all right well first and foremost
congratulations
on your wedding has anything changed
like you feared submit but i saw many
people
things changed like people change now i
feel so relaxed i feel like that i can
love jenny more than i are you i was
doing it before i mean like that time i
was loving too
but now i'm free i'm so relaxed and i
feel more love for him we're more happy
i would say we're more happy now good i
know us fans who are rooting for you are
like we told you submit we knew you were
going to feel better like relax yeah so
how long have you officially been
married now four months couple months
now and
you know almost four months okay well i
want to talk about your looks for your
wedding day you both looked amazing
actually we just we just went shopping
at the mall went to my favorite uh
designer clothing store in the mall
richard kumar famous designer here in
india
and we went in her store and
we just i just told her why i was there
and what i was looking for they started
bringing me
wedding attire you know stuff to try on
and i think that dress
what i got married in was the first
thing that i tried on and
i was just like wow yeah you know this
is the one that i want as he choose a
thing so i thought like then it's my
time to uh time for shopping
and we find something a little bit
similar color to that and we feel like
that that's a perfect match now be
taking opportunity to
declare it here by i at horizon
you not only got married without telling
your parents submit
but you got married in the temple when
the astrologer mentioned that in order
for your mayor should be successful you
have to get married in the court we
don't want him to have another divorce
god willing everything will go good
what are your thoughts on that now i
know he gave you permission the night
before you got married but what is he
saying about it now
yeah actually i was a bit scared about
it because i know that whenever he
predicts something i
it like 99 it always come true so i was
scared that if we get married and
in a temple and the things will go
according according to his prediction
then it means that we're gonna
uh uh
end up uh
divorcing very soon and that was scaring
me
uh that's why i call him and i ask him
that like it's
no chance that i can marry her in uh
like in a code because
then i have to wait for 30 days and then
maybe more than that like it it's a time
consuming process so he told me that
uh
you are trying your best to marry uh you
are trying your best to uh have a good
relationship but this is your staff
those are pushing you towards the
uh that route where it can cause you
trouble so he said okay uh just no
problem then go get married to uh
temple and
uh with all the rituals and all that uh
rest he want us to go to him and do some
remedies like
he was gonna suggest us some
uh solution how we can reduce the impact
i found that so interesting how he said
it seems like the stars were making you
do it the quote-unquote wrong way
right
that's so interesting first of all shout
out to your astrologer
he is the real mvp of
this season
he's a breakout star people want to see
more of him they were even saying maybe
a spin-off series they want to see him
read other 90-day castmates
do you think that that would be
something he would be open to
oh actually
i don't know about it uh he's very
straightforward uh person
uh he will never tell you something just
to please you or like that and sometimes
he say like things which you don't like
which you don't want to hear but it's
it's about a solid this is his study
this is what he do
and he will lie or something then
how do you think he wants his own
spin-off show
what do you think do you think he will
yeah if he gets invited a lot of people
will get upset too yeah well some people
need the hard truth after filing that
marriage uh
application i put it on a hole i asked
him to put it on hold
smith looking back now
how do you feel about blocking your
marriage to jenny behind her back to be
very honest that i feel like that i was
scared
and i don't want to go into a marriage
or where i'm not ready for it and i
think it's a right choice uh to stop it
and uh and i think that's how it um it
worked for us that i i realized that
that
that
that i'm ready now i realized that i
able to talk to jenny and i able to
realize that that this is the time so i
think whatever happened in past was
a worth it and and
it's not wrong at all i i take my time
might be like a couple of days or
whatever but i think it's right yeah
something i really appreciated was your
honesty you mentioned how your past
trauma like unresolved fears and issues
you really weren't aware of came up when
it was time for you to get married again
and i think so many people can relate to
that because we have moments where we're
happy in life a happy moment comes but
here comes our trauma just coming out of
nowhere
so is that something you're actively
working on healing the trauma you've
experienced from your arranged marriage
actually
it's a big thing
it's a big
long duration trauma
when i was in my marriage so
you can say that after uh i get divorced
or when jenny come to uh come to my life
once again
and after that i
start forgetting about all the stuff i i
forget everything i don't even remember
that what the wrong thing happened with
me who did something wrong to me because
i don't want to think about it right
actually helped me most likely jenny
helped me most because when i'm with
jenny i i can't even think of a wrong
thing happened to me i can't think about
like what my parents said but my in-law
said but
ex-wife did nothing the only thing is my
mind is positivity but when it comes to
marriage
uh when the marriage part came so you
can say that all of a sudden uh that all
the trauma all the
a bad experience strike back again
and and that's why i was scared i i know
that jenny's the one i know her since
since a long time and i love her too
but still the marriage is the that world
marriage starts scaring me it's very
quickly it's happening very quickly some
fans were confused that you were saying
it's all happening very quickly yet you
two were together for almost a decade
but your explanation it makes sense it
was just the term or the idea of
marriage that was freaking you out not
necessarily mirroring jenny
yeah yeah just a matter it's like an
idea marriage was the one thing that
were freaking me out
and you can say that once i had a bad
experience with the marriage so
obviously i will get scared of
but i know that she's the best one and i
got the best one i kept saying but it's
me it's jenny what is that's what we all
kept saying submit you've been with you
for this like you've been happy i mean
for this long beside all the drama with
your parents but do you still have that
fear that marriage will change jenny
down the line or have you moved past
that um you can say that i won't say
that it's uh
it's their heart but might be point
person in the back of my mind
maybe you're gonna change
no actually i don't have fear
actually i'm experience uh experiencing
uh the kind of a partner i want in my
life the kind of
a partner i should i i get in my life so
this is the best one like i'm living my
best married life yeah oh and i will say
submit you are a lucky
man
you're a lucky man i mean not
not many people in their lifetime are
going to experience a love like jenny
like the love jenny has for you
and what she's sacrificed and done so
you're lucky yeah actually she's lucky
too
she is but jenny jenny's been through it
we've watched her go through it for this
love and we you too
but
you're a lucky one but i always knew he
loved me and i always felt his love i'm
the one that's in the relationship
i'm the one that's going through
everything with him i'm one that knows
everything
so i know he loves me i mean i i have
sense you know and i could feel it right
i mean us women we can feel it if it's
if they don't love you you can feel that
and i never felt that i never felt that
he didn't love me not one time
so i knew he did and so i never worried
about it at all i just
continued on with the with the
relationship with them because we both
love each other so much and we just
wanted to be together and that was that
was the goal
yeah yeah well i'm excited for this
tell-all submit yeah do your parents
know
you're married
you're gonna tell left today today oh my
god
i'd like to say hello to sadhna and
annel how are you
fine
submit is there anything you want to say
to your parents
[Music]
are you going to tell your parents that
you two are finally married that's what
it looks like
yeah i actually thought what it looks
like and you need to wait and watch for
that stay tuned
well
tell me this jenny are you at least
invited to family celebrations now
because that would say a lot if you are
i i'm not going to say i can't say i'm
not going to talk about that
and actually there's no family function
happening that hardly watched it
yeah yeah not yet okay well jenny you've
been pushing for this marriage for years
looking back now
the weight the drama
was it all worth it
of course of course it was and i was
never i i was never pushing submit to
marry me um
i know it looks that way but it i never
was i mean
i if we want to stay together and uh if
i want to stay living with him in india
it's kind of something that we did have
to do and
that we chose to because we don't want
to be apart from each other we we don't
want to go a different route you know we
just
we we've been happy we've been living
together all this time and we didn't
want anything to end we wanted just
everything continue
so
you know
we could have not we if he wouldn't have
married me
you know we'd still be together we
we still would but
i might
us living together in india might be a
little bit harder because you know i
have to have the visa to be here so
right right right well
i can say this along with a lot of other
people we're so excited for you both and
grateful that the day finally came
we're proud of you so many we're pushing
through you pushed through submit you
did it
[Laughter]
[Music]
you